وبامل انتصار والتقدم اكثر في كاس العالم
2020 يدخل المنتخب المغربي بعد ظهر اليوم
او ظهرا في توقيت المغرب يدخل لقائه
المرتقب امام المنتخب الاسباني في اختبار
جديد لاسود الاطلس بعد تصدرهم لمجموعتهم
في الدوري الاول يتسلحوا المنتخب المغربي
بدعم الجماهير كبير مغربيا وعربيا حيث يمن
الجمهور المغربي والعربي بانتصار عربي
جديد في مونديال قطر يدخل العرب لاول مره
في تاريخ مشاركاتهم في الدور ربع النهائي
الى المزيد من الارقام من المغرب معك من
جديد
اه ثلاثوا لقاءات جماعه المغرب واسبانيا
في السابق كانت كلها في الاطار الرسمي في
عام
1961 التقى المنتخبان لحساب تصفيات كاس
العالم في مبارتين لتحديد المتاهل
لمونديال تشيلي فاز فيهما المنتخب
الاسباني في مجموعه مرتين بنتيجه اربع
اهداف مقابل هدفين اللقاء الثالث جمع
المنتخب في مونديال روسيا 2018 وانتهى
بالتعادل الايجابي بهدفين لمثلهما في كاس
العالم الحالي حقق المنتخب المغربي الفوز
في مبارتين وتعادل في واحده متصدر
مجموعاته فيما تاهل المنتخب الاسباني في
صعوبه بعد تحقيقه لفوز واحد مقابل تعادل
وخساره مفاجاه امام اليابان بهدفين مقابل
هدف
سجل المنتخب المغربي في كاس العالم الحالي
اربعه اهداف وتلقى هدفا واحدا فيما سجل
المنتخب الاسباني 9 اهداف وتلقى ثلاثه
اهداف على كل حال سالنا الجمهور في المغرب
عن توقعاتهم لمباراه الحاسمه مع المنتخب
الاسباني في الدور الثاني لكاس العالم
نشاهد
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
اكيد ان شاء الله
غادي نكون في موعد ديال المباراه ان شاء
الله
ونتمنى الفريق الوطني
التوفيق ان شاء الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
2010 2014
[تصفيق]
الحمد لله المنتخب المغربي يقدم بزاف هذه
المباريات زوينين ضد منتخبات كبيره وان
شاء الله كان ضمن المنتخب المغربي غادي
يفرحنا ان شاء الله غدا ونتمنى له يوصل ان
شاء الله
[موسيقى]
الاطلس في مواجهه الموتور الاسباني اليوم
البارحه ضغط على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
الحديث عن ازمه التذاكر تذاكر المباراه
حدثنا اكثر عن استعدادات المباراه الحاسمه
سهام طبعا اكثر طلب ان يصلي وانا مالي
علاقه نهائيا في الاماكن العامه من
الجمهور المغرب بيسالوني عن التذاكر رغم
انه
رغم انه فيفا طرح امس 5000 تذكره مخصصه
للمنتخب او جمهور المنتخب المغربي عاده
سهام همم فيفا يحرس انه يكون المدرجات
ممتلئه بالجماهير فاذا كان هناك يعني
تذاكر مباعه ولكن اصحابه ما صدر وبطاقه
هيئه وما ما يعني جزء تذاكر للوصول الى
قطر همم يقوم الفيفا باعاده الطرحه مجددا
للجماهير الراغبه بالامس خصصها للمنتخب او
الجمهور المغربي لكن امس يعني كان في موقف
جميل جمع ما بين همم سعوديين ومغاربه
كانوا السعوديين اللي كنت تذاكر مباراه
المغرب والمغرب يكون تذاكر السعوديه طبعا
بالصدفه كانوا شاهين المباراه التذاكر
المباراه هذه من من فتره طويله بالصدفه
صارت مباراه
واحضروا وخصيصا للدوحه لدعم المنتخب
المغربي لكن ده يعني سهام انا اعيش من
الوضع هنا موجود المغرب لها دعم كبير جدا
يقذفوه
خدود اسود الاطلس في هذه المباراه ضد
اسبانيا خصوصا بعد الاداء المتميز خلال
المباريات السابقه
سهام انه ما نحكم على اسبانيا في مباراه
قدام
اليابان او خسارتها من اليابان في
المباراه
في كلام كثير هنا انه اسباني يتعمد تخسر
من امام اليابان عشان ما تقابل للبوازير
في دور 16 هذه اعطيني مؤشر انه اسبانيا
بتظهر بشكل مختلف في دور 16 لكن في جانب
مهم بجانب معنوي اعتقد انه له تاثير كبير
جدا على لاعبين المنتخب المغربي همم في
همم موجود امهات كثير من اللاعبين همم
متواجدين في المونديال يدعمون اللاعبين في
التمارين يدعمون وما ايضا داخل المعسكر
ويدعمون في المدرجات بس سهام تخيل انت
يعني اي شخص طبيعي انه والدته موجوده في
المدرج وهو في ارض الملعب حيطلع كلمه عند
عشان يرضيها ويسعدها وهم دائما حتى
الامهات يتعمدوهم يحفزون لاعيبتهم
بالاسماء فتره التسخين فهذا يعني
دافع معنوي كبير
[موسيقى]
للاعبين المغاربه في بعد
امر ايجابي في هدوء كبير في معسكر المنتخب
المغربي في صفاء بين اللاعبين في تفاوض
توافق بين اللاعبين هذا سهام مؤشر تودائما
مهم ودائما يعكس لك يعكس على ادائه نتائج
المنتخب اذا المنتخب داخليا اذا اللاعبين
ملتمين على بعض مع المدرب دائما
والمغرب 2014